episode 1 the opening scene features a
married couple Henry and Claire who are
talking to an interviewer they recount
their separate experiences of what time
travel is like Henry possesses a special
ability he can travel through time
however he calls it a disability because
it seems to have affected the normaly of
his life he cannot control the when and
where of his travels sometimes
disappearing for hours days weeks or
even months according to Henry one of
the major problems of time travel is
that he cannot carry any clothes from
the present time and always ends up
naked after transporting to a different
reality as a result he has learned how
to steal fight and run because they're
the basic skills for him to survive
against the odds in different time
frames and nine places out of 10 that he
ends up flashing is meant with
aggression for Claire she just hears the
water running or she'll walk into the
room and see a pile of clothes and
that's when she realizes that he's gone
again she then has to wait and worry
until he's back when a question arises
about their first meeting the scene
flashes back to the past a 20-year-old
Claire who studies at the school of the
Art Institute of Chicago is seen
visiting the Newberry Library there she
encounters 28-year-old Henry who works
as a librarian CLA recognizes him even
though he doesn't recall her she reveals
details about a scar on his forehead
beneath his long hair and a
strawberry-shaped birth mark on his foot
shocked and perplexed Henry wonders how
she knows such details about him you've
been following on Twitch she answers
that she met 14 years ago when she was
young that time she met the older
version of Henry and now she is meeting
the younger version this is the reason
why he doesn't recognize her yet later
the two meet for dinner in order to
discuss the matter in more detail CLA
hands him a journal containing 152 dates
that he had dictated to her it's the
date that he would be showing up to see
her Henry is obviously unaware of this
as it was the older version who did the
dictating as their conversation unfolds
Claire reveals that she first met him
when she was very young she was playing
in the garden when she heard his voice
from the bush a 36-year-old Henry
introduced himself as her new friend
creepy and requested her to arrange some
clothes for him creepier as a result she
went home and stole her father's clothes
from his closet Henry then revealed
himself not like that after putting on
the clothes and that's when she saw the
birth mark on his foot he told the girl
that he's going to reappear many times
in the future she looked confused so he
explained exp some rules about time
traveling he also recounts how time
traveling was first explained to him the
scene further shifts back in time when a
7-year-old Henry is seen visiting a
museum with his parents Upon returning
home he asks his mother to revisit the
museum to which she agrees later that
night the young Henry time travels for
the first time and returns to the museum
where he meets the 28-year-old version
of himself the older version says that
he'll meet him more often and will be
teaching him everything about time
travel before they can converse further
though they're transported to another
time frame the 28-year-old one ends up
in front of a couple completely naked he
then beats up the guy steals his clothes
and goes to meet Claire at the
restaurant continuing the earlier scene
it's romantic so we're going to gloss
over the fact that Henry's a criminal
after dinner Henry brings her to his
apartment which is in a completely
messed up State he then blindfolds her
okay Jesus Henry and asks her to count
to 100 while he quickly cleans it up
once done he removes her blindfold and
the two start making out out the
following morning CLA uses his bathroom
only to find the underwear of another
girl turns out that Henry has a
girlfriend named Ingrid this obviously
makes her mad prompting her to walk away
in Anger the 36-year-old Henry who is
talking to six-year-old Claire gets
teleported to this time frame and
Witnesses Claire's storming off he
follows her to a local bar and offers an
apology on behalf of his younger self
Claire expresses her frustration that
she gets the younger version of him when
it's this one she knows knows and loves
however he somehow manages to console
her after which he goes to talk to the
younger version who is waiting outside
the bar he advises the younger Henry to
focus on two things finding the love of
his life and dying as slowly as possible
you got that you little idiot afterward
the older Henry travels back to his own
reality and Cuddles with his sleeping
wife episode 2 the scene then cuts to an
incident when 8-year-old Henry and his
mother Annette drive to the airport to
pick up his father on a Christmas
morning A Joyful occasion takes a tragic
turn as their car is hit by another
vehicle resulting in a severe accident
that claims Annette's life Henry
narrates that this haunting memory stays
vividly imprinted in his mind and he
travels back to this particular incident
over and over again the scene ends with
Henry from various stages of his life
standing and witnessing the gruesome
death of his mother next we see
28-year-old Henry and 20-year-old CLA
arguing on a train he is pressuring her
into going on a second date CLA refuses
expressing her disinterest in this
version of Henry since she had
fantasized about his older self however
he claims that they can't change what's
faded to happen as a result they end up
in a cafe the spot they were meant to be
at there a man painted in green brings
her a banana latte now that's
Serendipity this reminds her of how old
Henry had told her that he would talk
about his mother on this very day upon
inquiring he finally discloses his
mother's name and andette Lynn Robinson
Claire instantly recognizes her as a
renowned opera singer who met a tragic
end in a car accident this realization
makes her feel bad for him but he says
that he still gets to see her being a
time traveler and all he shares
instances of witnessing his parents
engagement and interacting with them in
a park even playing with a baby version
of himself but the baby kept beating him
at peekaboo not really pissed him off
Henry proceeds to reveal that he
repeatedly traveled back in time to
train his 8-year y- old self on skills
such as stealing clothes money and other
surviving Essentials during the training
the younger Henry said that his mother
is dead but the older Henry knew that
she hasn't reached that fate yet hearing
this the younger Henry wondered if he
could save her but the older version
claimed that they can't change anyone's
fate to prove it the older Henry
predicted that he'll rise from his chair
and run in approximately 30 seconds
surely enough the young Henry saw his
mother and rushed towards her he tried
to warn her about the impending accident
and revealed his time traveling
abilities however she dismissed his
concerns as mere excuses for skipping
school and berated him instead Henry
explains to CLA how after trying and
failing each time he realized that he
cannot change the events that occur in
time after their lunch Henry takes CLA
to the library to show her a memory box
containing recordings of his mother's
performances among them is a tape
recording of her show and the pair sits
down to listen amidst this Henry
confesses that he had never listened to
the tape before because these memories
acted like bear traps that would make
him feel stressed and transport him back
to the past however he also believes
that this is an opportunity for Claire
to meet his mother this leaves her
perplexed but Henry insists that she
think of a question she wants to ask his
mother CLA poses this one how do couples
manage to stay together through time
when Henry plays the recording Annette
says a gentleman asked her a question on
behalf of Claire she answers the
question saying that couples get
together just for a while but it's it's
better to be happy for a little while
than to just be okay your entire life
stunned Claire asks how that happened to
which Henry replies that the question
was asked by his older self who had
traveled to his mother's past episode
three back at present the elderly Claire
shares her Bizarre Love Story to the
audience she compares her old age with
her young age because both involve
waiting she recalls how she was 6 years
old when she first met her soulmate
during one visit Henry mentions that he
would meet her parents when she would be
20 this triggers something in her mind
and wonders who she is to Henry in the
future she knows that he had a wife
named CLA but he never confirms anything
more about it one day Clare bolsters the
courage to ask Henry if she would be his
wife in the future which he denies the
present CLA thinks that what he did was
the safest way to deal with a
13-year-old girl one night she is woken
up by Henry's scream she runs towards
the woods only to find his father and
brother engaged in shooting she also
discovers a patch of blood in the snow
which soon disappears from her sight
this hints at Henry's accident that will
impact his future Clare then shares it
with Henry in their next meeting but he
doesn't seem to be bothered by it as
Clare turns 16 we see her starting to
flirt with Henry she refuses to give him
his clothes and makes him win Checkers
to get them back they also go to the
park and have ice cream together which
is when they are noticed by Claire's
school friends and then Henry Goes to
Jail the next time Henry visits he finds
cla's note stating that she has gone to
a party she leaves him with a sandwich
and some clothes though while he waits
at their usual spot CLA is at the party
with school friends there she becomes
attracted to a sportsman named Jason
later on the party seems to have turned
into a disaster as CLA disheveled and
covered in dirt frantically searches for
Henry at their meeting point as soon as
she finds him Henry disappears on their
next encounter CLA is in a dark mood and
takes Henry for a car ride on the way
she asks him to introduce his younger
self to her Henry rejects the idea
asserting that their meeting will occur
when it is meant to fueled by anger and
frustration CLA drives the car at a
scary fast speed reasoning that there's
no way they can die since he already
knows a future version of her however
Henry persuades her asserting that the
future is built on the choices she makes
now as they come to a stop Claire makes
a strange request she asks Henry to kill
Jason she believes that he can easily
disappear even if he gets arrested after
a while of contemplation the 32-year-old
Henry contacts his 24-year-old self who
works at the library he asks the younger
version not to be alone for the night as
he will need an alibi from 8 to 10 p.m.
following this Henry and CLA drive to
Jason's house and abduct him using her
father's gun even though she plans to
kill him CLA brings his inhaler along
with her soon after she changes her mind
and now she wants him to suffer not die
perplexed Henry seeks an explanation
prompting Claire to disclose what
happened that night with her she exits
the car and reveals the bruises on her
body she clarifies that he assaulted her
but didn't force himself on her however
the present CLA narrates that she lied
to Henry as Jason did indeed do dirty
things to her she believes that by
sharing the truth it'll always be a part
of their story according to her account
we learn that Henry has already passed
away by this point back back in the past
Henry is shocked and enraged now wanting
to take matters into his own hands he
binds Jason to a tree and holds him at
gunpoint Jason tries to prove his
innocence by referring to the texts CLA
had sent him after that night according
to him she was happy and had enjoyed the
night in response CLA explains that she
sent those texts out of fear that Jason
would harm her Henry shouts at him
saying that she can never enjoy such an
experience and he knows her because
she's his wife this Revelation lead CLA
stunned but Henry vanishes before they
can delve deeper into the conversation
alone now CLA summons all of her friends
who would have been abused by Jason they
then surround him and write their
stories of pain on his body episode 4 in
the following scene we see 20-year-old
CLA preparing dinner for Henry with the
help of her best friend Sharice and her
boyfriend Gomez Clare tries her best to
cook a decent meal but fails because of
this Henry decides to help her as they
are busy preparing dinner the doorbell
suddenly Rings it's 41-year-old Henry
who has just time traveled and wants
shelter at cla's apartment despite
initial reservations Henry permits his
older self inside upon learning that
he's being pursued by the police for
appearing naked in public we then cut to
the Past meeting when Claire switches
out Henry's clothes for a suit it's her
18th birthday and their last meeting for
another two years according to the dates
mentioned by him CLA wants to make this
day memorable and desires intimacy Henry
thinks it's a bad idea to engage in a
physical relationship before the time
it's meant to be but despite this
reluctance he falls for the charms of
CLA and gives in to Temptation classic
Henry after spending the night together
he time travels to cla's apartment
disrupting the earlier dinner scene the
next scene features 19-year-old Claire
who has ended up sleeping with Gomez
while her best friend is away boy Henry
and Claire really deserve each other
soon after the guilt overcomes her
because she just betrayed her only best
friend seeing her cry Gomez admits that
he loves Claire more than he does
Sharice but despite this CLA makes it
clear that it won't happen again because
she loves Henry whom she'll meet again
after a year after leaving her apartment
a heartbroken Gomez tries to drink away
his sorrow outside the bar he notices a
couple engaged in a heated argument the
couple is none other than 28-year-old
Henry and his girlfriend ingred Gomez
interferes and holds Henry on off so the
woman can get away this is the first
time when Gomez met Harry and it goes
about as well as When Harry Met Sally
later that night Sharice reveals that
she has feelings for CLA and kisses her
this unexpected action prompts CLA to
push her away claiming that she never
wants to get in between her and Gomez
despite this reluctance the two best
friends end up sleeping together every
character in this movie is about as
Randy as Austin Powers yes that was a
British accent yeah back to the dinner
scene Claire tries to hide the presence
of the two Henry's from Gomez and
Sharice but to make the matters worse
ingred arrives at the apartment Sharice
perceives ingred as Henry's friend so
she allows her inside ingred heads
straight to Claire's room but she
doesn't appear phased by the presence of
two Henry's as she's aware of his time
traveling ability ingred loves the young
Henry while CLA admires the old Henry
yet they're both lovers of the same man
as a result the jealousy between the two
girls is evident but they try to
maintain a code of conduct and a
full-blown orgy ensues after this the
elderly Henry suggests that they explain
their situation to Claire's friends who
are waiting for them in the kitchen as
anticipated Gomez and Sharice are
startled to witness the two Henry's at
the same time they believe them to be
twin brothers but Henry tells them about
his time traveling Gene to demonstrate
this ability he provides Gomez with a
list of stocks to invest in Claire then
asks Henry to use his capabilities to
prevent calamities and save the world
however he declines emphasizing the
impossibility of altering life events
through time except for getting rich off
the stock market I guess this is the
reason why he considers himself as a man
with a genetic disorder experiencing
life in a chaotic sequence rather than
considering himself a superhero amidst
their discussion ingred asks about her
future when Henry remains answerless she
asks if she's dead all that he can say
is that she doesn't have much time left
left which breaks her down into tears
Jesus Henry in an attempt to console her
he remarks that everyone will eventually
die in the future he even believes that
his life can perhaps be over by the time
he turns 42 because that's the oldest
he's been so far but just because he
knows his time will soon end doesn't
mean he'll stop experiencing life at
last he gives her a comforting hug and
disappears that was poetic but it was
still a dick move from Henry episode 5
in the next scene 20 28-year-old Henry
meets Gomez at a local bar they try to
forge a friendship because the two are
meant to be best friends in the future
Henry can't stop his humorous self from
making fun of his future best friend
which only offends Gomez he also can't
believe that Gomez becomes his best
friend because he can't stand him right
now the scene then shifts to a flashback
that shows 16-year-old Claire meeting
38-year-old Henry at their usual meeting
place she draws him naked even though he
is fully clothed she refuses to show him
but he seems to be aware of the eventual
outcome he knows how much of a horn dog
she is after the bar meeting CLA takes
28-year-old Henry to meet her family on
their way Gomez keeps calling Henry to
mend their relationship though it's
again Henry's humor that exacerbates the
situation upon arriving at their
destination Claire's parents Philip and
Lucille and her brother Mark greet Henry
at the door as they sit together for a
meal Philip asks about Henry's future
career plans however he seems
disappointed to learn that Henry aims to
be a librarian and nothing more after
some formalities CLA gives Henry a
partial tour of the house but she avoids
showing him the meadow where she used to
meet the older Henry the following
morning cla's younger sister Alicia
introduces herself by trying to get
Henry to kiss her while he's in the
bathroom Alicia is aware of Henry's time
traveling secret because she has seen
Claire talk to a naked man whose
appearance changed over time and she got
time travel out of that CLA had to
explain the truth to Alicia rather than
have her report the incident to their
parents unfortunately the stress of
Alicia's introduction triggers Henry to
time travel Claire now has to stall
lunch earning Henry some time to get
back from wherever he ended up we then
see Henry land naked on top of an angry
biker gang member outside a bar the
mobster doesn't take it in a calm way
which ensues a brawl between the two
Henry somehow manages to gain control
but he's soon outnumbered and gets
beaten up just then then Gomez arrives
at the scene and scares off the gang by
pointing out that the nearby
surveillance cameras are catching their
illegal activities and if their other
biker friends see the footage of them
with a naked guy what might they think
following this Henry and Gomez head to a
bar where they discuss how they both
love the same woman Sydney Sweeney I
mean Claire Gomez admits that he loves
her despite knowing the fact that she
loves Henry and that he has no chance
with her it is at this moment that Gomez
confesses the first time he saw Henry it
was through the sketch that Claire Drew
of him after hearing all of this Henry
jokingly asks if Gomez wants to wipe him
out of the picture so that he can try
his chances with CLA this causes Gomez's
expression to change and he seriously
admits that he would never wish that for
his best friend before Henry disappears
again Gomez tells him to make a note of
today's date and to tell Gomez's past
self about it Henry then returns to
cla's house where her family is waiting
for them to join them for lunch the
family members are clearly worried after
what witnessing the bruises on his face
Henry and Clare try to cover up the
truth from the family but they are
unable to come up with a believable
story moreover her brother keeps on
interrogating Henry in detail which
fuels CLA with anger as a result she
yells at Mark as well as her parents for
being so annoying and even ends up
slipping that she'll be marrying Henry
she then runs to the meadow hoping that
an older Henry will appear and comfort
her Henry goes to her room only to
discover his skch indicating the love
and admiration Claire has for his older
self realizing that she needs him Henry
seeks help from Alicia who is a
hairdresser by profession he asks her to
cut his hair short and apply some makeup
to look similar to Old Henry meanwhile
CLA finds that her once magical place
now looks different with adult eyes
there's garbage everywhere and an
industrial plant blowing smoke in the
distance shortly after Henry approaches
her from behind her anger melts away as
she recognizes the resent resemblance to
the older version that she admires this
triggers a flood of fond memories spent
with the older Henry in the past Henry
also promises her to be the one she
admires this moment wins Claire's heart
and they end up sharing a romantic kiss
episode 6 in the subsequent scene we see
28-year-old Henry and 20-year-old CLA
who are busy planning their wedding
however the thought of their future
together makes Henry anxious leading to
more time traveling he frequently
travels to the Future and ends up in
their new lavish house he wanders around
the house and takes note of a
distinctive tree that consistently marks
his visits to the Future furthermore he
notices how a video camera is set up in
front of a desk and a wheelchair behind
it which indicates that he will injure
his foot in the future or maybe Wall-E
was right and in the future everyone
will be in shares back to 28-year-old
Henry he tells Claire that he hates
videos unlike the rest of the world who
cherish their happy memor memories from
the past Henry finds himself compelled
to relive those moments over and over
again therefore in the world of Henry
videos don't make much sense despite
this Claire insists that their wedding
is an important day and wishes to film
it properly apart from this Henry
struggles with the fact that his dad is
going to be at their wedding here it is
revealed that he has a strained
relationship with his father ever since
his mother's passing one day Henry takes
CLA to meet his father and shares the
news of their marriage surpris
surprisingly The Old Man and CLA get
along in quite a smooth manner from this
day onwards Henry initiates more
frequent visits and calls to his father
during one such visit he confides in dad
about his apprehensions he expresses his
fear of potentially disappearing on his
wedding day since he is experiencing a
lot of time travel lately he also
considers the use of drugs to keep
himself calm in response his father
suggests that he see a doctor but Henry
refuses claiming that he'll be
apprehended if his time traveling thing
is disclosed in another instance of time
travel to the Future Henry hears CLA
sobbing alone in bed clutching an ornate
box he is completely unaware of the
situation which causes him to be
stressed and time travel into the
present time Henry then questions
20-year-old Claire about the box to
which she replies that her mother gave
it to her to store precious jewelry
though it's currently empty as the
wedding day approaches Henry's anxiety
intensifies because he becomes
increasingly concerned about leaving CLA
alone at the altar he shares his fear
with her but she isn't worried because
she knows that their future marriage is
inevitable in a desperate attempt to
resolve this issue Henry goes to meet
his old friend Ben who is now a drug
dealer Henry asks him for a drug that
can keep him calm for at least 9 hours
his friend then hands him a highly dosed
morphine pill Henry decides to give it a
try right away causing him to pass out
following this Henry experiences
numerous time travels to the Future in a
Non-Stop manner first he Witnesses the
older Henry engaged in a heated argument
with CLA which gets him even more
worried he travels back to the present
for a few moments before traveling again
during the second trip he sees CLA
grieving with Gomez at a funeral
subsequently in his third trip Henry
finds cla's ornate box with several
positive pregnancy tests this time he
overhears his older selft talking on the
phone saying how Claire thinks he's a
murderer he approaches the older Henry
to inquire about the matter as they talk
the younger Henry learns that Claire has
gone through several miscarriages it
turns out that a Time Traveler's child
also experiences time travel despite
being inside the womb let's see what the
biker gang does when that lands on their
head as a result the couple is
struggling to bring their baby into the
world upon asking what he did to hurt
CLA the older Henry replies that he made
a big decision without informing Claire
he underwent a vasectomy because he
couldn't see her in pain any any longer
this decision shattered her hope of
giving birth to a child which is the
reason why she is upset this Revelation
also infuriates 28-year-old Henry who
vehemently declares he will never take
such a drastic step however the older
Henry says that he'll do the exact same
because he can't change the future
fueled by anger the younger Henry
punches the older one prompting the
latter to time travel back to the
wedding day meanwhile the young Henry
remains an older Henry's reality and
spends the rest of the evening with the
future CLA Henry's father and Gomez are
glad to have him back at the right time
the only problem is that it's the old
Henry who has gray hair to resolve this
issue they Ed black shoe polish to color
his hair after this they all head to the
church for the wedding ceremony
simultaneously the future CLA plays
their wedding video so that the younger
Henry can watch the events unfolding in
his own time frame at the wedding CLA
walks down the aisle and soon realizes
the switch between the two Henry's
despite this she plays along and the
ceremony goes seamlessly she is finally
married not to the man she originally
anticipated but to a version of him from
another timeline meanwhile in the future
Clare confides in the younger Henry
saying how she wanted his children more
than anything in the world however she
is upset that he gave up after five
attempts this makes the younger Henry
feel sad because he's supposed to make
her happy Claire tells him that love is
not only about being happy together but
also about dealing with tough situations
as a team she also says that if he
forgives her when she hurts him she'll
try to do the same for him as they
Converse CLA expresses that she misses
the younger Henry and asks him to keep
visiting her time and again she shows
sexual interest in young Henry primarily
because he hasn't gotten a vasectomy yet
and also boyed as he bounce back fast
she believes that she has a chance to
get pregnant with him or at least they
can try it's clear that they can't have
a child under normal circumstances but
an exceptional one might make that
possible the show ends with both
versions of the couple from different
timelines sharing a romantic kiss
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching